season six of outlander is finally here
and we've got the inside scoop about
what's going on behind the scenes let's
travel to the past and see what we
uncover from the series this far into a
marriage a couple can still
be as passionate with each other as they
were from the beginning number one
better late than never finally on its
sixth season an intimacy coordinator was
added to the crew at the behest of sam
hewitt he'd said on the matter i brought
on board the intimacy advisor vanessa
coffey because with intimate scenes it's
important that everyone is protected but
also we find a way to explore these
scenes and actually maybe get something
more out of them did you know that
intimacy coordinators aren't just used
to keep actors safe but also make the
scenes as compelling as possible it's a
win-win for the director and actors
it's always been a goal of the cast and
crew that the sexual scenes are balanced
out between the genders the creators
have been wanting to eliminate any
objectification number 2. how did kovid
get into the 1700s
we only have time travel to blame covid
precautions added a challenge to the
everyday working environment in the
height of winter which is not normally
when they shoot the series katrina belf
said that kovid was definitely a
challenge while lauren lyle admitted it
was a mad time to film i went on a lot
of walks ate a lot of great pasta and we
watched a lot of great episodes of the
office us that isn't the show we'd
picture the cast watching but we'll take
it number three it probably wasn't a fun
time on set for katrina four five six
months pregnant right towards the end
when we were doing all the action stuff
challenging valve was more than halfway
through her pregnancy while filming
season six
this complicated things for her quite a
bit as she'd mentioned on a personal
level i was pregnant the entirety of the
season so that was quite challenging
just in terms of the energy that's
needed to film outlander and how
difficult it is sometimes to film
i'm exhausted number four nobody cut
corners while making these costumes
that's for sure there's a lot of hand
sewing that's gone into these costumes
just as authentic to the wearer and the
designer as the audience we're doing a
lot of hand sewing there's no zippers
there's no velcro
there's no snaps
the corsets are laced together
we had the precursors to pockets which
are pouches the outer layer of mrs
fitzgibbon's dress had gaps in the skirt
so she can pull these pouches right out
can we please bring this trend back we
need somewhere to put our iphone
number 5. if the cabin isn't real is
fraser's ridge is anything real anymore
so much thought goes into the set
dressing and the fraser's ridge cabin is
an important one to get right including
the little apothecary so this box
actually is a gift from jamie declare
it's one of the top gifts jamie has ever
given her probably right after brianna
they're gonna airbnb this between we are
the frasers ridge cabin is just a set
located in scotland are you surprised at
all its beauty represents the love that
it lives within it
number six how much money would you
demand to be paid to put live maggots on
your skin in season five sam hewitt
actually had to have live maggots poured
on his leg and the poor man was just as
petrified as the viewers of the show
katrina belf was less afraid but was
surprised how bad they smelled saying
they had an unpleasant stench of rotting
flesh oh god what is that smell and the
worst part happened at the end when they
were counting them back up and realized
they were short a maggot or two
hopefully they didn't get caught in
sam's prosthetic number 7. inspiration
can come from the oddest of places
sometimes it comes from shower thoughts
sometimes a strange interaction with a
friend and sometimes it can come from a
25 year old doctor who episode you heard
that right the inspiration for the
outlander book series came partially
from an episode of doctor who when she'd
first started considering writing the
book she was questioning where and when
she wanted it located she figured
historical fiction would be the easiest
for her due to having an entire
university library at hand in this
malleable mood happened to see a really
old doctor who rerun on public
television the doctor picked up
earthlings from different periods of
earth's history and he'd picked up a
young scot from the 18th century look it
doesn't really matter where you said it
important thing is get started number
eight it might have been easier to just
film in canada more than 100 first
nations actors came from canada to
scotland to play the native american
roles in the fourth season since they'd
built out the entire mohawk village in
fascilate forest just south of
cairngorm's national park and just 30
minutes from the set of the fictional
crigna doomstones producer and writer
matthew b roberts said for probably
about a year we researched these long
houses that the mohawk would build and
we essentially built a village filming
took place for an entire month number
nine you could say the crew had more
structure than the plot did sometimes
that's a slight at time travel not the
writing the writing staff was set up so
that half of them knew the books and
half of them didn't this was intentional
as a way to try and please both fans of
the books and new fans of the show the
writer put up a fight to turn this book
series into a tv show and not three two
hour movies she just didn't think it
would do the material justice as there
was just so much to cover remember how
confused you were when you watched
inception yeah this would be worse they
had all chosen katrina's
out of this entire mass number ten in a
twist of fate the male lead was easier
to find than the female lead it only
took four days to find an actor to play
jaime fraser and they thought it would
be super hard author diana gabaldon
didn't think the actor looked like jaime
at first but turns out that's because
his googlable images looked nothing like
him the second sam spoke she knew that
was jamie on the other hand katrina took
four months to find it was only three
days before filming was supposed to
start when she was chosen everyone in
control of casting had settled on the
irish actor because there was something
about her another one said that's the
same one i picked
prior to outlander katrina belf had done
very little acting she went to france
originally to be a model after having a
stable modeling career for about a
decade she's done over 250 runway shows
and she was at the height of her career
considered one of the most in-demand
models in the world she'd only had very
small acting roles up until she was
casted in outlander claire was her first
lead ever number 11. we're totally
wigging out over this weird fact did you
know that there are over 300 wigs and
counting in outlander and hewin had to
dye his hair every three weeks as he's a
natural blonde number 12 the nice thing
about a back prosthetic is you only need
it when the character is shirtless to
get jamie's back scars put on human
spent three hours in the makeup chair
every day he had his shirt off he made
the smart choice and would take a nap it
must be easier to catch some z's when
the prosthetic is on your back and not
your face it's made with silicone and
the color of the scars are done up a bit
lighter every season to imply that
they're fading with time number 13. if
you tell the truth you don't have to
remember anything true in theory in
practice you need to panic learn to ride
a horse
well actually you just need a super
understanding director who doesn't
recast you immediately both lead actors
lied in their auditions about being able
to ride horses they had to do two weeks
of boot camp to learn riding fighting
gaelic and to handle weapons although
katrina already spoke gaelic so she
might have been able to take a day off
katrina has been reunited with her
season one horse for season six his name
by the way is travis and katrina called
him a dreamboat
season six of outlander is shaping up to
be just as intense if not more intense
than season five and before we end this
video we just have to mention how
awesome the outlander fans are did you
hear they have planted like 120 000
trees for katrina's birthday talk about
amazing did you plant a tree and are you
as excited as us for season six let us
know in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things